for three weeks the world has been
asking a question where is pungshui
this looks like china's attempt to
answer it
miss pong apparently attended a tennis
tournament on sunday morning
we wanted to verify that and went to the
national tennis center in beijing
the tournament was over but staff there
said they had seen that earlier as they
escorted us out
are the videos released by state media
over the weekend showed miss pong at a
restaurant the date saturday the 20th of
november is pointedly mentioned out loud
five times
the restaurant was busy for sunday lunch
when we visited
and staff said she had been there
so this is the restaurant pong shui came
to last night staff have told her that
although they didn't see her themselves
and the video does seem to show her safe
and sound at least what it can't show of
course is the circumstances beyond that
and also the nature of those allegations
she made back at the start of november
it's the most we've seen of punxsuit
since she accused jean-gal lee a senior
communist politician of pressuring her
into sex but none of this was published
by pong herself chinese state media not
her is providing the updates
and her weibo account where she first
published the allegations is still
blocked
that's all left many unconvinced
including the women's tennis association
which has been unflinching in demanding
more information from the chinese
authorities
steve simon the ceo the wta wrote
while it is positive to see her it
remains unclear if she is free and able
to make decisions and take actions on
her own without coercion or external
interference this video alone is
insufficient as i've stated from the
beginning i remain concerned about
punctualized health and safety and that
the allegation of sexual assault is
being censored and swept under the rug
the question where is pungshui has
always been a shorthand a rallying cry
from the tennis world her appearance is
welcome
but the bigger trickier questions about
her allegations
about her whereabouts since she made
them about her freedom now have not been
answered yet tom cheshire sky news
beijing